when you're in front of other humans
your behavior changes and you don't
behave the same way in front of your
family your loved ones you know your
friends your enemies
that's true the cops
you're just someone else
how do you like to create characters so
when when you're when it's based on real
people
the challenge is to understand who they
are
beyond the obvious
meaning you know and you'll see this
with biopics
it's um such a
especially when they don't work right
it's
i don't want to get the public persona
because i can find that on youtube
um
um especially you know if it's
indulgent and um
yeah mostly lazy you know self-conscious
so
i'm not gonna talk bad criticize any
biopics but it's like i already knew
that you know that's an actor playing
that guy
um
but i want to see what happens backstage
i want to see what happens when they're
alone i want to see who they were before
they were
well known or confident about themselves
i want to see what they do when yeah
when the world is not watching
so um
[Music]
with the chicago script actually got a
chance to talk to the guy
who it was based on um
and that was
that was a big there was a big challenge
in there because he was a he was a
revolutionary and i think he still is a
revolutionary
so when he read my script um
of course you don't know you never adapt
reality exactly as it is you gotta
change it up a bit and you get adapted
for it to be a story because reality is
chaos
stories have a structure right
and you gotta fudge the facts a little
bit not too much
ideally
so he wanted to be like a documentary so
he basically called me all sorts of
names we had a great relationship until
he read the script and he was like
no you didn't
write it exactly as i told you i'm like
well that's not a story
anyway that's
neither here nor there but
what you're trying to understand the
person
how they see the world their
contradictions
um
you know
how
how they are three-dimensional people
when you're making up characters it's
not that different in the sense that
you're trying to find in your own
database
um attitudes that resonate and that
would build a possible individual
um
and some just filter in there when
you're writing you know as i said you
know when you write a a couple fighting
or or a daughter a mother and daughter
fight or
father and son fight whatever
it's hard not to think of your own
experience
either intentionally or unintentionally
um
so
um
there are guiding questions you can use
always
i remember those there was like a six
question
questionnaire
that uh neil landau gave me at ucla
again i had great instructors at ucla
and people who i i still talk to
um
and it was basically
the questions were like what's um
what's the trait that most um
that you like least about yourself
you know it was like
introspection questions but then how to
apply that to character like what's your
crutch what's your strength
um
so again when i when i teach character
uh on ucla i mean they're
um i give them multiple techniques
ask all the possible questions observe
there's an exercise i make them do where
it's like eavesdrop people don't be
creepy but you know when you go to
supermarket
eavesdrop in conversations and see how
people
um relate to one another
just um in terms of dialogue right
notice how
some people don't finish their sentences
notice how
the euphemisms what they avoid saying
notice what they actually say and what's
implied with their body language
absolutely i mean observation is always
the key to character and dialogue
walking down the santa monica strand
you could pick up fantastic conversation
you don't even have to eavesdrop you're
just there and people
um yeah they're not even you know
they're not even concealing what they're
they're just saying without i'd say
anywhere in l.a
cities
the truth is if you're a curious person
you'll find characters anywhere
it doesn't have to be la it can be
any town
um
just notice how people are very specific
you know about
how they present themselves
i always say this would to to my
students when they have to pitch like
remember that you're not it's not just
your words it's how you present yourself
they've already started judging you when
the moment you came in
so you know choose how you're going to
dress for that meeting how you're going
to present yourself
just because know that they're
they're paying attention
right
um
the same thing with the characters is
you know how do they dress do they care
about how they look do they care about
appearances do they not
how do they feel about aging
you know do they care if they're
wrinkled or do they not care at all
or are they over compensating
exactly aging do they have any physical
issues that affects their personality i
mean not per se what i'm saying is that
affects the personality
usually there's a connection
sure
yeah or are they always another thing is
someone that's always bragging about
themselves
that that's speaks volumes yeah
um well that's you know
it's always um that's why i like to have
characters intimate moments because
um
it's very your persona and um
your actual self are very different how
many people are depressed and we don't
know it that's right i mean and now
thankfully we're talking about it in
public but even now i mean i'm trying to
be honest with you but there's a part of
me that this is my persona i mean we
can't help it you know i'm doing the
same thing i mean
i'm doing my best to be myself but you
know
just even here
yeah
when you're in front of other humans
your behavior changes and you don't
behave the same way in front of your
family your loved ones you know your
friends your enemies
that's true the cops
you're just someone else
the checker at the you you're happy hey
how was your day oh great hey oh
everything's we have so many things you
know yeah so many masks
did you catch that game the other night
oh it was great yeah all right well you
take it easy if you go to the dmv
you're gonna try to be really friendly
because you know that those people hate
being they hate their jobs and i don't
blame them so you're like hey it's
beautiful whatever i don't know
how do you find out what a character
wants
i guess
i guess it has to be something that i'm
interested in
um
[Music]
sometimes character will come out of the
want comes first
the quest comes first and then
i mean it's not always the same it's
always different but sometimes
you want to explore a certain quest and
then you wonder who would be the most
interesting person to me
in this quest in this mission
so is it the most
um
adequate person or is it the most or
really a fish out of water you know so
um
i have a thing where um i tend to have
characters on a spiritual or
um
abstract
quests
and it's it's really an issue i don't
make it easy on myself they don't want
material things i've managed to figure
this out over time
and i've i've
had some problems with people like
what's the goal i don't get it it's like
she won't she's trying to become
this or he's trying to understand
um with lyrics he's like he's trying to
find he promised harvard
the
the future of psychology
the new method and that's why he got
hired
and he doesn't know what that is
so and his students hate him and if he
doesn't find that method he promised
them he's going to be out of a job
a widower without a job at 40 with two
kids
and by 40 i mean 1960
40 year old not today being to 40
nothing that's nothing but in 1960 don
draper was 36.
so if you were 40 you were old
um so he's you know
he's trying to find something and he
doesn't know what it is
and i like those sorts of challenges um
it does you know it does um turn me into
someone of an intellectual writer i
guess because i'm pursuing ideas
um
but that's okay i mean if i guess if the
day i want to write a script about uh
people pursuing money i can
it's always easier if what they want is
a loved one
or money you know because it's tangible
what if it's the idea that they think
money will
i mean what if it's this elusive care
that okay they get the money but then it
doesn't
fix what they thought it would fix oh
but i think that's inevitable that's the
thing you know it's the thing with the
want and the need right
so they want money
but they need
to change you know the way they're
approaching life in general i don't know
so it's this idea that before the
midpoint there's a want and after the
midpoint it's about the need
and movies are usually i mean there's a
moral element to movies hollywood movies
at least which is
you know they were they were trying to
be the biggest um
investors in wall street and it's
actually about
uh finding someone who loves you
this is a classic i mean we've seen this
over and over and over again right
he thought he was after the job and he
was actually after love
[Music]
but it's easier if you say it's a movie
about people desperate for money
of course when you actually watch the
movie it's not about that
you know
the want is usually not doesn't define
what the movie is about
and the reason why this works it might
sound schematic but the reason why it
works is that that's how people actually
are we you know we
there's a lot of denial i feel like in
everyday life and we tell ourselves we
want thing and we don't really know what
we want or you know what we need
of course movies do that in 90 minutes
or two hours but
in life you realize years later that you
know i was pursuing i thought i wanted
to make it big in hollywood and i
actually wanted to you know i don't know
heal my wounds from the past
if it rings the bell it's because a lot
of people are going through that sure
well a lot of people that go into
entertainment sure there's
interesting things that drive them um
incredibly happy satisfied people don't
need to tell stories you don't think so
um
there's nothing dramatic about it and i
feel like no i'm not saying we should be
miserable let me clear clarify this i
don't think we all should be tortured
and and sad i'm saying that um movies
need a certain dramatic element a moment
of conflict
no one wants to see a movie about two
people who are perfectly in love
all the time
that's true um
i'm not you know i'm not trying to be
dogmatic what i'm saying is that we you
need events and this and then but
you know it can be and and and has to be
like but however you know and
so
um
i don't know i i personally feel like
the need to express yourself comes from
something that you need to understand
something that you're lacking something
that
you could say the same for someone who
writes a piece of code
they're creating something there's an
artistry to that code
sure i've never written code so i can't
talk about that i mean i
any anytime you create something it's
because you feel like something's
missing right
that's what i'm saying like you're not
it doesn't come from a place of total
satisfaction
um
i'm not saying there should be something
missing in your life and if you get and
if whoever gets to a point where they
feel totally satisfied
man i'm sure that's awesome i'd love to
be there but
i feel like the second you you become
enlightened and at peace with the
universe and everything
i don't know why i would sit down and
write a script you know i'd be just i'd
be basking in existence
i see
you know not not to get too
philosophical and
um
and again i don't mean that you have to
be a tortured soul
no
and i'm sure the people that write
you know the classic
come back home for the high school
reunion and you know it's all in a neat
package and it turns out everything
works out okay you know that that's not
that's different than
somebody who writes about you know
scamming investors on wall street or
something i mean there's a different
different mindset there may be i don't
know there's room for everyone look um
this is the thing the the audience
again i think the audience is smart so
if you if you have a movie or a story
where um
a family is totally at ease and they're
all happy together
after probably
10 minutes or 15 the audience is going
to be like something's going to happen
you know something something's bad is
going to happen and then
half hour goes by and they're like
wait when's something going to happen
and then you know an hour goes by and
they're perfectly happy eating peanut
butter sandwiches and you're like what
am i watching there's nothing happening
right
so that's you know even if you want to
write a perfectly happy story the
audience is expecting something some
conflict
and and i don't i don't feel conflict is
something artificial that you insert
into the story life is full of conflict
you know like
out there it's just
you're stuck in traffic that's conflict
it's not someone died but you're like oh
my god i can't get to like wait i can't
wait to get out of my car and i've been
in traffic for half an hour and i got to
use the restroom and oh my god i'm going
to get home and i haven't bought food
for the cats
that's conflict all the time